foreign
most of what we know about performing
leadership
is made of up of these um practice
postures
passed down in the west through a white
male
embodiment of power
these have become so intertwined with
actually having power that imitating
these behaviors kind of feels like the
only way to show up with authority
we can obviously do better than that
I work in organizational and leadership
development and I'm an artist I believe
artists are leaders in expressing things
that humankind often doesn't know how to
say yet so that's why I invited a bunch
of artists to do a leadership makeover
they wrote public addresses
they made leadership portraits I call
them the artists in presidents
since 2020 over 70 artists and
presidents have contributed to the
digital archive they're North American
indigenous International and stateless
they're artists with disabilities
they're queer
they made beautiful attempts at
embodying inclusive performances of
leadership and Power
Samsung others looked to repair the past
one person used artificial intelligence
to write her speech and one person just
straight up wrote a curse
and so many more
but what really surprised me was that a
lot of us struggled to say something new
to articulate what we want with
authority
blame it on a millennia of humans
colonizing humans but it seems like we
don't believe we can have the things we
want the things that we need to live and
work with dignity
so I think as leaders
interested in investing in an equitable
Society modeling agency is one of the
most important things that we can do for
our communities and organizations
but it's hard
how do you move towards believing in
your own agency
the way that I learned to do this came
in a really unusual place
when I was in my early 20s I met Captain
Betsy
I was queer depressed feeling totally
alone
in my tiny South Texas town on the Gulf
of Mexico
and by the time Betsy landed in my town
she had been living on homemade rafts
for decades with a group called The
Floating neutrinos she had captained
over a dozen rafts including one across
the Atlantic Ocean
in that thing
so the floating neutrinos believe that
the most important thing a person needs
to know how to do is articulate their
own desires to break out of being solely
in reaction to the systems that contain
us like the economic system and the
education system
so that we can allow our deepest desires
to be the thing that bring Direction and
urgency to our lives
the rafts were a tool that the neutrinos
use to bring themselves closer to their
desires so obviously I was very taken by
this not because I wanted to permanently
live on a raft but because I wanted to
believe in an extraordinary life
and Betsy was the first person to ever
ask me what it is that I wanted
and she did this using a practice called
the three deepest desires she'd say
pretend you're gonna die
you're gonna die you're all gonna die
um pretend that you're gonna die
tomorrow
what is one thing that you need to do
before you die and then I would have
full on drama meltdowns around answering
this question because it was impossible
for me to believe that I had any
authority over my own life that I could
want things outside of what my parents
and our culture had told us to want
so Betsy finally said look all you have
to do is answer this question for today
you could say I want to eat the biggest
hamburger in the world okay great
whatever write it down because you're
going to answer this question again
tomorrow and it's how you answer this
question over time that matters
and so then I said something super weird
like I want to see a waterfall because
there's no waterfalls in South Texas and
I got much better at it
saying what we want out loud is
something that we have to practice but
the Crux of this learning is the
believing part believing Faith it's not
something that we learn in isolation
it's something that we learn through
imitation like leadership and language
so in my life Betsy modeled for me what
it meant to articulate my desires and in
lending her faith to me she was also
giving it back to herself
but she did another thing
and this is something that leaders often
forget to do
she listened she sat with me in the pain
and discomfort of my process and it's
from that place my current reality that
she guided me towards a vision a
possibility and agency in this world
we can choose to model our leadership
styles in similar ways it's a commitment
to relationality
it's a process that never ends but it
pays off because it grows empowered
engaged and inspired groups of people
focused on a shared vision
so if what we want is to connect
people's priorities with our Visions for
the greater good we have to commit to
mediating between the truth that is in
the room and the aspirational future
you're all going to die
you could die tomorrow
what's one thing that you want to do
before you die
what kind of leader do you want to be
thank you
[Applause]